you mentioned julio jones and that was a
couple of years when matt ryan got to 30
million a year julio was at 15. right
simple analysis matt ryan's not two
times better than me i want more now
it's that julio jones high watermark of
22 million per year set last year by
jones for all receivers that's where
deandre hopkins wants to be that's one
of the reasons why the houston texans
made the move that they did
stunning us all the first day of the
league year back in march trading
deandre hopkins to the arizona cardinals
and it was a given then number one
hopkins wants that julio jones type
contract number two the cardinals
would do something at some point problem
is haven't done it yet
and deandre hopkins hasn't practiced yet
and deandre hopkins took to twitter to
say
that
he is not holding out that was in
response to a question from our friend
john mclean of the houston chronicle
asking that question is deandre hopkins
holding out
hopkins says i'm not from the source not
holding out no he's not holding out
because he's there he's holding in yeah
and that's fine we're not going to
question him we're not going look you
got the teams always use every tool in
the box to help themselves leverage the
best possible deals the best possible
situations the best possible outcomes
they can players have every right to do
it too and if you're deandre hopkins and
you've been slightly injured or not
injured at all you're working the system
to get what you want to get what they
apparently i don't know if they promised
it per se
but it was all pointing towards they
know what they were signing up for right
right
they were stepping into the exact shoes
of the houston texans who had grown
exasperated with the reality that andre
hopkins wanted julio jones money and
they didn't want to pay it to him so now
the cardinals step into that and he
doesn't step onto the field until he
gets it it's that simple now i know that
the pandemic has complicated things
chris but hey the deal went down after
the pandemic started and it didn't take
a nostradamus to figure out there was
going to be financial chaos in the nfl
this season and next season deandre
hopkins still wants his money and yeah
he's not holding out but
i think he's holding in and i have no
problem with it if he is no me neither
you know you know my guy that's what i
always respect about you you you always
respect the players ability to negotiate
and play hardball you know in an arena
that's you know not made for them in a
lot of ways when we know that you know
players are football players they're not
business men as compared to the gm and
you know more times than not the owner
this i mean deandre hopkins has
tremendous leverage here we know that i
mean come on it's one of the big stories
of the off-season deandre hopkins
arizona cardinals him and kyler murray
and wow they're gonna spread the field
and deandre hopkins is gonna you know
just be
wide open all over the place and this is
gonna be amazing you know yeah he he he
he deserves to be paid big money i mean
again like melvin ingram this is even
more egregious to me where there's guys
in front of him right now that certainly
are not in his class we could talk about
amari cooper amari cooper you know yeah
i love amari cooper you know that he's
talented as hell but he's making four
million dollars a year than deandre
hopkins he ain't deandre hopkins and
what he's done the last few years and
deandre hopkins is in his prime so it's
a dicey situation for a deandre hopkins
you know yeah you know you want more
money but you're going to a new team so
you don't want to be that jerk and set
off the the you know the relationship on
the wrong foot there
uh and i would imagine that arizona
knows that this was coming like we've
talked about and then this is something
that's going to get done and they better
be working on it right now because
they're not going to win games of their
defense this year i could tell you that
they are built to win with their offense
and they need de'andre hopkins
practicing and getting on the same page
with murray
and you know what as
we were having this conversation
talking about melvin ingram talking
about deandre hopkins at one point i
think melvin ingram was with caa who
represents joey bose so melvin ingram
currently is with athletes first there's
a database available to the media that
shows who represents whom in the nfl
yeah and i was in the process of
reconfirming who at caa represents
deandre hopkins and
what when you put in and just to go
behind the curtain how this database
works if you put in the player's last
name it brings up all the players in the
nfl with that name right and it shows
who their agent is and if the player's
name doesn't show up on the list it
means the player currently doesn't have
an agent at all
and deandre hopkins name
is not showing up on this list right now
it could be a glitch in the nflpa system
right but it also could be an indication
something and i sat here and i thought
you know what do i really want to talk
about this because other people are now
going to chase it maybe they'll break it
officially i don't care i want the
audience to know what we do here to give
them the latest information it looks
like deandre hopkins based upon what i
see right now on the nflpa website
i don't think he's got an agent right
now which would suggest a greater level
of disharmony dysfunction
dissatisfaction behind the scenes that
he hasn't gotten his julio jones deal
which points even more strongly to this
being deandre hopkins holding it yeah
well
i mean i i you know that's interesting
wrinkle i mean it makes it more personal
it makes it more you know tough i think
on the player to deal with this you know
to be there and okay yeah you're doing
football stuff and then what at some
point you're going to go up and have to
talk to the gm and the owner and start
diving into numbers and things like that
you know
no no no it doesn't mean he's
representing himself no okay but there's
there's a five-day gap a mandatory
five-day gap between parting ways with
one agent and signing with another it's
quite possible we just kind of stumbled
into this while he's in his five-day
window where maybe he's in the process
of signing with someone else yeah yeah
yeah that he's not happy that look this
is what i want i haven't gotten it so
i'm just pissed off at everybody i'm
unhappy with my agents they're gone i'm
unhappy with the team i'm not practicing
uh but i'm not holding out yeah we agree
with that he's not holding out but but
it feels like something bigger is going
on here well yeah and you know yeah i
mean we'll watch what that what happens
in that development i mean that'll be
interesting but you know the other thing
too i bet you hopkins a little bit is a
little
you know for lack of a better phrase
feelings hurt or you know what i'm
trying to say here mike is you know yeah
we know he was going to ask the texans
for more money i'm sure when he saw this
trade go down and arizona was going to
trade for him that arizona more than
likely
was informed that hopkins at some point
is going to want more money whether that
was from his 18th time yeah
right exactly so i think he's probably
sitting here now going wait you traded
for me there's all this excitement we
knew this was on the horizon and part of
the deal here and why i'm on the team
so why is it that now it's you know the
middle
august we're still sitting here waiting
to get this done when we knew this was
part of you know the pie anyways and we
got to get it done so you know i i
understand it and i understand that he's
being underpaid for what he's doing on
the football field the last few years
and uh he's got tremendous leverage here
i think it's only a matter of time
before they pay him
and now's the time to take a stand and
now's the time to get paid you do not
want to wait because after two more
seasons the window opens on kyler murray
to get his second contract now is the
time for the cardinals to spend the cap
dollars spend the money and load the
cannon with people around kyler murray
before kylo murray is the one who isn't
holding out but maybe holding in because
after the next two seasons he's going to
want his contract and he should get his
contract
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports